oui comme aline bonjour et merci d'être
heureux en direct avec monsieur rt
france alors réfléchir a été destitué en
2019 à l'époque les autorités
soudanaises de transition avait pris
l'engagement justement de le remettre à
la cour pénale internationale puisqu'il
a accusé de crimes de guerre et de
crimes contre l'humanité dans le conflit
au darfour pourquoi avoir attendu dix
ans avant justement de le remettre à la
france que d'évoquer soudanaises ont
beaucoup de dossiers à gérer il ya déjà
le dossier de la réforme de l'état le
dossier de la coopération avec le soudan
du sud
et puis tous les dossiers de l'igad au
niveau de l'afrique de l'est qui sont
douces aussi urgent les uns que les
autres et donc remettre le président
omar el béchir à la cour pénale
internationale
cela fait des années aujourd'hui qu'ils
étaient poursuivis n'étaient pas
véritablement urgence donc aujourd'hui
ils ont pris la décision de le faire la
cour pénale doit être satisfaite laisse
les pays qui espérait que le président
soudanais serait traduit devant la
justice internationale doivent l'être
aussi mais je ne suis pas certain que
cela résolve le problème de fond des
droits de l'homme et de la gouvernance
au soudan est-ce que la nomination du
procureur général karim rana a changé
quelque chose à votre avis pour faire
justement accélérer cette décision
je ne sais pas ce qui a été l'élément
déclencheur de cette décision auprès des
autorités actuelles du soudan une chose
est certaine c'est que il ya un besoin
aujourd'hui de justice il ya un rôle
d'épouvantail que la cour pénale
internationale joue dans le monde entier
et en particulier en afrique parce que
le gros des dossiers qui sont traitées
pour l'instant pas la cour pénale sont
des dossiers africains et non de ce
point de vue là de nombreux pays
africains ont estimé des dirigeants
africains parce que quand on dit beyond
a l'impression que tout le monde est sur
la même longueur d'onde dans les pays
mais des dirigeants ont estimé que
c'était une justice qui était raciale
postcoloniale et surtout qu'elle faisait
la part belle
aux pays qui sont puissants mais
s'occuper très rapidement des cases
africain loool vous prenez le cas de la
colombie par exemple il a fallu 8 à 12
ans il a fallu une dizaine d'années pour
que le dossier de la colombie soit
présenté devant la justice de même pour
la géorgie où il a fallu huit ans pour
que la cour pénale c'est intéressant à
son dossier mais aucun dirigeant par
exemple concernant la guerre de des
états unis les opérations militaires
étaient à la solde des états-unis de la
france ou de n'importe quel autre
puissance n'ont été inquiétés le cas des
ouigours n'a pas été cité le cas
d'autres minorités qui sont menacées
dans le monde ne le sont pas mais
aujourd'hui on a une cour pénale
internationale qui a besoin de
crédibilité qui a besoin même en interne
de prouver que sa gestion ne posent pas
question or le fonds victimes de la cour
pénale internationale est aujourd'hui
quelque chose de vraiment très opaque
dans sa gestion et dans son
fonctionnement
donc toutes ces choses là font que c'est
souvent sur d'écouteurs deux dirigeants
sur des choses qui sont très
contestables était subjective que les
dirigeants sont envoyés à la cour pénale
internationale
vous venez de dire que la cour pénale
internationale chez un petit peu de
crédibilité dont tendance est dans cette
affaire peut être aussi pour plusieurs
raisons vous venez de mentionner mais
concernant le soudan on sait que comment
les péchés il est actuellement en prison
où il est a été reconnue de coupable de
corruption
quel serait le sens d'une nouvelle
condamnation par la justice
internationale pour les soudanais
le sens serait que ça fait longtemps que
les les associations de défense des
droits de l'homme au soudan comme à
l'extérieur du soudan ont demandé que le
président omar el béchir et surtout
toutes les personnes qui sont impliqués
dans les massacres qui ont eu lieu au
darfour dans le sud du soudan d'or dans
les états du sud du soudan que ces
crimes là choisi g et qu'il n'est pas
des punis t elle à sud parce que ceux
qui aboutirent au delà de l'injustice et
l'impunité et donc ça c'est une démarche
qui est louable mais est ce que la cour
pénale internationale est le seul moyen
d'obtenir le résultat escompté par les
victimes et à les associations de
défense de droits de l'homme là est la
vraie question et je ne suis pas certain
que la réponse soit forcément positive
au moelleux béchir qui a régné pendant
plus de trente ans au soudan un règne
sans partage
dans quel état at il laissé le soudan
après sa destitution
le soudain est aujourd'hui un pays sous
embargo
et quand on est souvent d'un procès pas
le meilleur moyen de développer le pays
le pays essaie de trouver un peu
d'oxygène à moi de nouvelles
coopérations internationales qui lui
permet de tenir le coup le pays
aujourd'hui divisée et également parce
qu'on ne peut pas oublier la perte du
soudan du sud qui est devenu un nouvel
état dans la configuration sur la scène
internationale donc toutes ces choses
font que le soudan aujourd'hui est
beaucoup plus faible qu'elle ne l'était
au moment où omar el-béchir a accédé au
pouvoir et ce n'est pas rien que de le
souligner les chinois et d'autres pays
sortent aujourd'hui au chevet de ce pays
en marge de l'hommage de toutes les
sanctions qui sont aujourd'hui effective
contre le pays mais ce n'est pas
suffisant ce sont des sondés des
solutions rapides qui sont utilisés pour
essayer de contrer une descente aux
enfers du soudan qui vit actuellement
des moments très difficiles comme la
commune biron il faut pas oublier que
omar el-béchir est arrivé par un coup
d'état en 1989 le procès a déjà été
reportée plusieurs fois pourquoi
justement la justice soudanaise piétine
sur ce côté là
elle quitte une peut-être parce qu'elle
voudrait se débarrasser d'eux du cas de
omar el béchir de omar el béchir on l'a
vu en côte d'ivoire par exemple je
j'extrapole mais quand vous prenez le
cas de certains pays africains où la
justice nationale pouvait opérer mais a
préféré saisir une instance qui est qui
devrait intervenir en bout de chaîne
quand toutes les procédures ont été
impossibles en interne vous prenez en
côte d'ivoire ça a était ce la reprise
et le kenya avec le président au boulou
kenyatta ça a été la même chose les la
justice est très vive la justice
internationale s'est très vite saisi du
dossier parce que en interne par moments
il y avait cette volonté de le faire il
y avait la volonté aussi de certains
partenaires diplomatiques il en soit
ainsi et donc les autorités ont obéi à
ses injonctions mais je crois qu'il ya
une nécessité aujourd'hui de faire que
l'impunité ne passe pas uniquement par
la cour pénale internationale
il faut défaire des cours un doc comme
ce fut le cas pour juger hissène habré
au niveau du sénégal pour que la justice
soit le plus près aussi des victimes et
que l'on ne soit pas dans cette
impression que la cour pénale
internationale n'est là que pour les
états faibles et rempli l'agenda et le
calendrier des pays les plus puissants
concernant les dirigeants des pays les
plus faibles merci beaucoup en tout cas
louis keumayou d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
présidente du club de l'information
africaine